okay so i'm gonna try to get us caught
up on some of the donald trump events of
the last 72 to 96 hours
there was a lot of craziness during the
tail end of our vacation donald trump
continuing to hold rallies as if there
were no pandemic often with
hundreds or thousands of people many
without masks mostly without masks
sometimes the people on stage behind
trump
do have to put masks on but the rallies
range
from horrifying to authoritarian to
dystopian to perverse and everything in
between there were notable
rallies in the past few days in north
carolina minnesota and nevada i'm going
to highlight different things in
different clips
notably the north carolina rally on
saturday which is where we will start
this was
post the death of ruth bader ginsburg
the country learned of the death of ruth
bader ginsburg during trump's friday
night rally which i will get to
this rally you will see a whole bunch of
nonsense related to rbg
so let's go through the key moments
trump having notable problems speaking
during this one even worse than the ones
earlier in the weekend
here is donald trump who has had a
renewed focus on the moon
and mars lately saying that the united
states will be the first station
to put an astronaut on nars with an end
take a look
we'll land the first woman on the moon
and the united states will be the first
nation
to land an astronaut on mars
on mars we have trump actually
just really struggling to put together a
sentence a number of verbal glitches at
this one
here is trump's short circuiting on the
word sanctity
just really odd almost like he choked on
his tongue
he will defend the dignity of work and
we will defend the sanctity
the sanctity of life then trump
struggling with nobel peace
prize several times calling it the nobel
priest
prize and then getting all mixed up and
and discombobulated not clear-headed
covered i got the nobel priest first
nomination
a peace prize nobel nomination
and then before we move into the meat of
it here he is
saying his own name wrong when you say
your own name wrong
that is another level referring to don
donald trump donald trump
okay that was the first little time then
he went donald trump
donald trump i love donald trump but
yeah
so not going well from the standpoint of
verbal
one of the sickest moments trump having
his supporters vote
by yelling as to whether they would
prefer
that he replaced ruth bader ginsburg
with a man
versus a woman it's almost like a
deleted
scene from saturday night live where
they said now this is
too stupid well it's reality
so women and men ready
would you rather have a woman in the
super supreme court or would you rather
have a man ready
a woman or a man so would you rather
have me
choose this very scientific poll
actually it's a lot more accurate than
these polls that interview like
97 people have been interviewed then you
know they charge you a million dollars
and they probably don't interview the
people they sit behind their desk and
just say
would you rather have a woman
on the supreme court yes woman yes
tom tiller says yes so would you rather
win or would you rather have a man on
the supreme court
everything is a game everything is a
joke a contest it's unserious in some
way with donald trump
still on ruth bader ginsburg early in
the rally donald trump
fed the line to the crowd fill that seat
kind of telling them it didn't naturally
surface donald trump telling the crowd
the chant now is fill that seat and then
trump
here uh um in in announcing that he will
uh in saying that he will announce ruth
bader ginsburg's
replacement this week or potential
replacement the crowd getting going with
phil that seat
and by the way we have plenty of time
there's a lot of time you know you're
talking about
you're talking about january 20th right
here's a video of donald trump telling
one of those
inane stories about people referring to
him as sir
and what's notable about this one is
that the crowd is almost completely
silent
trump's going on and on the crowd not
even remotely keyed into what the hell
trump is talking about check it out an
almost completely silent crowd the crowd
is so quiet
when one person reacts when one person
laughs
you hear them do you hear that stand out
take a look
5.7 billion sir i said that's a lot of
money
it's actually two planes you know air
force one is two planes i'll give you a
little they're going to say that's
classified information well they've been
flying around with two planes for 30
years
so i assumed somebody though and our air
force one is 31 years old right so you
know look it's time
a lot of the arab sheiks come in i see
they're playing they have a brand new
one i say what do we have 31 years
and we're protecting them why the hell
don't we have a new one
so i said so they finally had it 31
years old the new one's totally
different 7 47
it's much longer bigger wingspan much
more beautiful you know it's modern it's
beautiful
5.7 so i said to the head of boeing nice
guy dennis
this was before they had their
difficulty which is terrible what
happened to him but
that went on for a few minutes and
really relatable right like
billionaire president complains that
arab
sheiks have much nicer newer private
airplanes
than he gets to fly around in really a
man of the people
then trump sort of laughed about how
msnbc reporter ali velshi
was actually hit by rubber bullets while
covering protests refers to him as a cnn
reporter
details don't matter ali velshi's
actually with msnbc
trump again with a completely silent
crowd behind him
no first grade teacher has ever been
able to accomplish this
trump gets a huge crowd of people with
low attention spans to actually sit
completely quietly
full scene they lined up they went down
there was no social distancing in
between
these great tough guys there was no
social
distancing tom tillis they went down and
they had but
like 250 000 outfits they had more crap
in their helmet with
night goggles and these guys were sort
of you know wise guys right
shouting at him screaming at him they
were screaming at the wrong people they
went down they never had a stop it was
just forward
it all ended it all ended in minneapolis
it took
you all saw it what a half an hour
remember they hit the
cnn reporter and the knee he went down
ally velci he said
this is a friendly protest it's
wonderful to see
such a behind him it was all fire for
black
it looked like berlin during the war
this is a friendly what are they doing
how does that help to be
like that how does it help we're joined
tonight and then
donald trump rehabbing this conspiracy
theory
that joe biden got some kind of upper
before his debate with bernie which is
hilarious because trump's the one that
always seems to either be on uppers or
downers
depending on the day take a look at that
no but don't underestimate look he's
been doing this for 47 years
and i got a debate coming up with this
guy
no it's true you never know you never
know
they gave him a big fat shot in the ass
and he comes out
and for two hours he's better than ever
before you know
problem is what happens after that
now we're gonna ask for a drug test we
are i'd like to have a drug test
both of us i'll take it he'll take
because i watched him in the debates
with uh you know with all those people
those democrats
trump initially was speculating was
biden maybe
on something trump has now moved on with
no more evidence mind you
trump has moved on to saying biden got a
shot of something which improved his
performance during the debate
trump still seems to think that
coronavirus testing causes illness which
is just
wacky take a look at this billion people
we are up 50 million tests more than
india
in fact we're about to crack 100 million
tests
and when you test then you have does
this make sense and you have cases
so we do all this testing and i come
home and i turn on
nbc news it is so it is so
bad i think
nbc that's
not only msdnc i think nbc
with lester holt there's another beauty
hi lester
and then it got really weird i spent a
while on this clip
i don't know what trump is talking about
trump seems to say that
he would give himself a d as a grade
on his coronavirus response he never
explains why and it almost becomes
unclear whether trump thinks
a d is a good grade or a bad grade it's
a very strange clip
they stopped it from going into the rest
of china should have been stopped in
china
to defeat the china virus we launched
the largest industrial mobilization
since
world war ii somebody said what grade
would you give yourself i said a plus
but i would give myself a d i would say
i would give myself and my whole group
because mike pence is great
mike pence really was he worked so hard
and it's unfair he worked so hard the
ventilators the vaccines
the therapeutics now we have like this
trump noah d
isn't good it's just complete and utter
nonsense and then
finally in this dystopian event
donald trump actually admits he's
counting on the courts
to play a role in him winning
re-election on november 3rd take a look
at this
what we're going to have a victory
on november 3rd the likes of which
you've never seen
now we're counting on the federal court
system to make it so that we can
actually have an evening where we know
who wins okay
not where the votes are going to be
counted a week later or two weeks later
but in just three and a half years under
my administration
we've secured america's borders rebuilt
the awesome
power of the u.s military think of that
of course my reaction is we know we know
you're counting on the courts
fortunately biden also knows it and
seems to be lawyering up which i've been
saying for weeks he needs to do
and then absolute last thing donald
trump made headlines with this saying if
he loses to biden he will disappear
if i lose to him i don't know what i'm
gonna do i will never speak to you again
you'll never see me again i hope that
that's a promise
that should inspire us to get out and
vote so that was fayetteville
north carolina brain falling out
nonsense from donald trump
then we will work backwards going next
to
minnesota real quick i want to tell you
about our sponsor
magic spoon who have done something
awesome they've taken all of our
favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman's show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n